did you know the Bible says dogs have
souls and Spirits Genesis
21:19 animals have souls and
Ecclesiastes 3:19 to 21 says that
animals have Spirits so don't let anyone
tell you otherwise the Bible does not
say animals don't continue to
exist right after they die nor does it
say there won't be Resurrection it is an
argument from Silence you can show
enough evidence to demonstrate that they
too continue exist and will be
resurrected it's not explicit it's an
inference but don't let anyone lie to
you and tell you
otherwise that's why even and I don't
base it on near-death experiences that's
why even in near-death experiences
you'll hear people talk about seeing
dogs or
pets so let that encourage you let that
encourage you dogs die because their
souls their spirits leave their body
they are said to be living Souls like
Adam is Genesis 2:7 and Genesis 21:19 I
challenge every one of you to see the
Hebrews the same it says when God
breathed the Breath of Life in the
nostrils of man he became a living soul
but in Genesis 219 it says God brought
before Adam all living souls for him to
name them and it's referring to animals
and beasts and the follow of the year
and they're called living Souls the same
thing that Adam is called and in
Ecclesiastes 319 to 21
Solomon is wondering whether the spirit
of the Beast goes down and the spirit of
the man goes up so notice he
acknowledges they have Spirit but he
doesn't know whether the spirit of the
beast when the Beast dies goes down or
goes
up Ecclesiastes 3:19 to 20 21 and the
word there is
R
okay you see it says Adam called each
living creature the word living Soul
it's identical to Genesis 2:7 where it
says Adam became a living being so
animals beasts foul of the air humans
are living Souls they're animated by the
Holy Spirit and they're given Souls by
the Holy Spirit which is why no two dogs
are alike what what do you think why do
you think dogs are different or cats are
different because the Holy Spirit gave
them endowed them created them with
their unique Souls that animates their
bodies and makes them different just
like we have souls by the Holy Spirit
created by the spirit to make us
different and it's Ecclesiastes 31920
he's posting it for what happens to the
sons of men also happens to animals one
thing befalls them as one dies so dies
the other all go to one place all from
the dust and all return to dust but he
didn't quote 21 because Biden got a hold
them Ecclesiastes
3:21 so let me really quick comment on
this because I'm going to get aack in
the comment section who knows the spirit
of the sons of men right which goes
upward and the spirit of the animal
which goes down to the now he's asking a
question apart from Revelation from God
can he answer the question do you know
for certain if God doesn't make it known
whether the spirits of humans go up and
the spirits of animals go down notice
just like humans have Spirits so do
animals and in Genesis 2:19 the animals
and the father are said to be living
Souls the very thing Adam is called in
Genesis
2:7 you guys get
it and do not let anyone tell you
otherwise the Bible is silent about the
afterlife of animals and their
Resurrection because the Bible's
concerned about Humanity not
animals but we do know in the new heaven
Earth there'll be
animals right
that's why when people tell me hey
animals don't have souls what Bible you
reading sucker they don't have Spirits
so says you sucks being you
next I just gave you the
examples
right do you want more proof on this oh
boy man you guys suck you want me to
give you more proof on this can I give
you more proof that animals follow the
year have souls and Spirits given to
them by the Holy
Spirit created by the Holy Spirit which
the Holy Spirit has end downed them with
you want me to give you
more you want me to give you more
examples let's look at the flood story
you remember when God commanded animals
and birds to come in Paris 2 by
two Genesis
67 so St Thomas said the same thing good
Genesis 6:17 here you go watch the
language
here well I'm giving you scripture
Joseph so you can disagree with me but
keep your opinion to yourself I've
already studied this issue I'm convinced
and if you're not convinced that's okay
just don't debate me I don't want to
hear it Genesis 617 watch here Genesis
6117 and behold I myself am bringing
flood waters now watch the language on
the earth to destroy from under Heaven
All Flesh and which is the breath of
life everything that is on the Earth
shall die now when God destroyed
everything on Earth he destroyed animals
birds and humans and he says all of
them have Breath of Life in them the
very breath of life that God breathed in
the nostrils of Adam making him a living
Soul let me now make it more explicit
Genesis
7:15 Genesis 7:15
7:15 watch
here watch what it says
here and they went into the ark these
are the animals and the birds two by two
who went into the ark and they went into
the ark two by two of All Flesh in which
is the Breath of Life did you guys catch
it the animals and the birds that went
into the ark 2 by two have Breath of
Life in them now watch this one Sergeant
Grinch this one you're going to like
genesis
7:22 Genesis
7:22 this one is more
powerful but the problem is not all
translations render it
accurately Genesis
7:22 watch here Genesis
7:22 in whose nostrils was the breath of
the spirit of life all that was on the
dry land died excellent translation did
you catch it notice what you read in
Genesis
71522 the animals and the birds that
went into the ark two by two that were
flesh had Breath of Life in them but the
animals and the fowl and the humans that
were outside the ark they perished and
they were those who had in their
nostrils the breath from the spirit of
Life did you guys catch it
in the nostrils of all the birds of all
the animals and All Humans outside the
Ark in their nostrils was the breath
from the spirit who gives life so the
spirit the Holy Spirit who gives life
he's the one who gave them their breath
their souls to animate them and their
spirits but when they died he took that
out of
them so what more do you want from
scripture animals and birds have souls
have Spirits they have the Breath of
Life in their nostrils because the Holy
Spirit gave them and endowed them with
souls to animate them and make them
unique and
different there you go okay I mean I
don't know what else to tell you if you
disagree with me keep your PIN to
yourself you're not going to convince me
I've already studied the issue you don't
want to believe in me believe my that's
okay just don't debate me but don't be
Warriors in the comment section